[Music]
stood
waiting at the mouth of edo bay sweat
dripped down his brow as he peered into
the distance at the anchored ships
belching dark smoke into the air like so
many
floating volcanoes this
was not how it was supposed to happen
barbarian ships were supposed to go to
nagasaki
like always they had to
six days earlier as the alien black
hulls had steamed into view
his masters had scrambled to do anything
they could to avoid this moment
he had been the second imposter sent out
to convince them to leave
ordered by his overlords to pretend that
he himself
was the governor of uraga to placate the
stubborn visitors
who were insisting upon speaking to the
person in charge
but the canny sailors had again seen
through the ruse
and sent him back with nothing but
threats of force
and a gift white flags
the ships had stayed
so now here he was and here
everyone was
[Music]
thousands of samurai lined kurihama
beach
and behind them holidaying spectators
munching on snacks and gossiping
waiting for whatever was about to happen
for kayama the personal and public
failure of it was almost intolerable
and the tension close to overwhelming
and in that he was not alone
it was july 14th 1853
and the anxious and curious multitudes
had assembled
for one of the most unique events in
japanese history
the four gigantic dark american vessels
anchored just a stone's throw away had
cleared their decks
and run out their guns their test
firings had boomed provocatively around
the bay
the message for kaiyama had been clear
if the americans were attacked
japan's capital city edo would be
destroyed
entirely and the japanese were to use
the white flags to surrender
once the power of the foreign guns was
finally understood
commodore matthew calbreith perry of the
u.s
navy grizzled veteran of the 1812 and
mexican-american war had refused to meet
any but the highest ranked official
remaining aloof in his cabin
until now
shots of salute rang out around the bay
as 15
boats carrying 400 heavily armed men
put out from the enemy ships and rode
swiftly ashore
under their strange blue and red striped
and starred
banner the first men to alight wore
musical instruments
not weapons while behind them strode the
man who was clearly
the tono their lord matthew
perry he was flanked by two enormous
black-skinned men
bearing a mysterious ornate box
this was the nearest to japan's capital
that a foreign delegation had been
permitted to land
in over 200 years and the most
hostile foreign troops to set food on
japanese soil
since the last mongols were thrown back
into the sea
six hundred years before
the alien music catawold the barbarian
officers barked strange orders like dogs
and the box and the letter it contained
from the king of the enemy
a man they called their president was
handed over
to toda ujiyoshi finally
the true governor of uraga representing
his highness
the shogun the americans announced they
would be back
next april or may and wade anchor
it was all over in half an hour but they
were 30 minutes
that changed the world
[Music]
thirty years before the japanese scholar
izawa seishisai
had written today the alien barbarians
of the west
the lowly organs of the legs and feet of
the world
are dashing about across the seas
trampling
other countries underfoot and daring
with their squinting eyes and limping
feet
to override the noble nations what
manner of arrogance is this
now the arrogant alien barbarians of the
west
had accosted izawa's own country would
japan
be the last in a long line of noble
nations to be trampled underfoot
and overwhelmed
the u.s navy leviathans returned earlier
than promised in february 1854
and this time they negotiated for 23
days
before coming to terms but the
consequences were not just those
scrawled on the fine japanese paper
japan
as a nation had suffered a psychological
humiliation
and the treaty proved to be the first of
many increasingly insulting deals
she would be strong armed into signing
over the next decade
finally prized open by the hungry grip
of colonial powers the u.s navy's brazen
infraction
started a ripple that would eventually
turn into a powerful wave
and then an unstoppable tsunami to shape
the coming 20th century indeed
within 50 years of perry's gunboat
diplomacy
the once peripheral semi-feudal japan
had become one of the most powerful
nations
on earth but why was
japan so isolated what had led
to its generations of long distrust of
foreigners
its need to keep the world at arm's
length
while the rest of the world had been
clamoring outwards and
slowly connecting across the years what
had kept japan's gaze
firmly inwards this
is that story a story that reaches
centuries back
and continues to mold the world today
this is the story of japan
and the west
the perry incident can trace its roots
back more than three centuries
to a time when japan was only vaguely
aware of the world outside
gosankoku the three civilized realms of
japan
the chinese ming empire and tenjiku
the lands of buddha's birth the northern
india of today that mongols arabs and
other barbarians existed was known
but they were generally of little
concern aside of course
from when they charged in to kill
pillage and burn as they had when
genghis khan and his successors had
destroyed
china and korea and only the shinpo
divine winds
had saved japan from being overwhelmed
by the mongol war machine
whether 16th century europeans were
among the known barbarians is unclear
but christendom as it was generally
known at the time by its own inhabitants
was a realm obsessed with accessing
the legendary riches of china and japan
or as they knew it cathay
marco polo had described the land of
chippangu
with semi breathless amazement as a
place where the dead were buried with
giant red pearls in their mouths
and the rulers palace was roofed and
floored
in gold two fingers thick
generations of western european
adventurers had dribbled
with greed but there was a vast
and seemingly insurmountable problem
they had no
real idea how they could get there
the known overland and red sea routes
through which oriental products such as
silk normally reached europe
were controlled by enemy muslim empires
and as far as they could ascertain no
other sea route existed
columbus and others knowing by now that
the earth was round
hypothesized that chipangu must lie on
the other side
of the great ocean and it would provide
an ideal base
from which to commence trade with the
great khan
in china but when columbus managed to
cross that very ocean his men
found not chipangu but a whole new world
that they had not even known existed
the portuguese meanwhile were trying
another way inching
slowly slowly ever further around the
tip of africa
in their search of oriental wealth and
prester john
a mythical christian king who they
believed ruled an eastern kingdom
with whom to ally in their struggle
against
islam after 50 years of attempts
they achieved their goal and vasco de
gamas small fleet
entered the indian ocean in 1498.
in africa and asia realms used to a
grand affair than the portuguese
possessed
ruler after ruler failed to be impressed
with the poor quality
and meager quantity of the european
gifts
so the portuguese did what they did best
and resorted to piracy
portuguese fleets moved ruthlessly ever
eastwards year by year
seizing bases and strongholds in africa
and asia to provide their fleets with
infrastructure and supplies rumors of
their behavior
spread like wildfire
the guangdong tong-ji recorded that the
falangi kidnapped
numerous small children under 10 years
old
roasting and eating them the people of
guangdong
were terrified it took the portuguese
several decades to regain a modicum of
trust
and only when they turned mercenary to
destroy pirates on china's behalf
were the tables turned
at some point the portuguese encountered
their first japanese people
probably equally cutthroat pirates
raiding the coast of china
or perhaps traders in a south east asian
port
and so finally after centuries of
european speculation
and salivation marco polo's famed land
of pearls and gold was nearly
within their grasp
some years ago in the ten bun era a big
ship
arrived at dawn at nishinomura bay
no one knew from what country it came
there were some 100 people on board
among whom there were those whose
physical features differed from
ours and whose language was not
understood
so relates the tepo ki or the record of
the musket
a 1606 history from the remote
tanegashima island
just off the southern coast of kyushu
recording the supposed first
contact between the far west and japan
and that was what first connected these
two vastly different cultures
guns but not in the way in which
connections were being made
2 000 miles across the ocean by spanish
conquistadors and the indigenous people
of the americas
on board this chinese junk were two
possibly three
strangely dressed long-nosed men whom
the chinese crew
helpfully described as south western
barbarians
showing their feelings without any
self-control
and not knowing the written script or
the use of it
such traders are in the habit of roving
from place to place
bartering things which they have for
things which they do not have
they are not very strange and are with
all
quite harmless
they were in fact antonio de mota
francisco zemoto
and some say their colleague antonio
peshotto
the first recorded europeans on japanese
soil the traders would not have found
the riches they were expecting on the
long sandy beaches
and gentle green hills of the low-lying
island
they did however find a people who were
exceedingly interested
in the strange weapons they carried
the local japanese lord tokitaka was
most impressed with this wondrous
tepo firearm
and snapped one up immediately
a swordsmith called kiosada was ordered
to reproduce this machine
so he stripped the gun and reverse
engineered it
everything worked perfectly apart from
the screw to seal the barrel
legend has it that he offered one of the
portuguese merchants his daughter wakasa
in exchange for the secret of how to
complete the firearm
the man unfortunately did not know but
returned the next year
with a specialist who did
japan's first ordnance industry was born
and in a remarkable twist of ballistic
history tenegoshima
is now the site of japan's main rocket
station
[Music]
kyosada was a heartless father but a
far-sighted military visionary
by the end of the century it is said
that japanese armies
wielded more guns than existed in the
whole of the rest of the world
combined
it was a case of right place right time
for this european weaponry
for the portuguese had unwittingly
sailed right
into the middle of a civil war of
mammoth
proportions it is known now
as the age of the country at
war
north south east and west grappled for
survival
and domination pirates such as the
murakami clan
viewed for control of the seas fanatic
warrior monks carved out vast
monasterial domains samurai warlords led
armies that made their european
equivalents look like modest militias
while ninja jealously guarded their
independent mountain domains
and hired their covert services to
whoever
would pay guns of course
fit extremely comfortably into this era
of extreme
civil strife some clans developed their
own
large-scale gun industries almost
overnight
others accepted christ into their hearts
as the necessary price of obtaining
portuguese weaponry
for of course jesuit missionaries
followed speedily in the gun runner's
[Music]
wake
while at malacca i learned great news
from some portuguese merchants
very trustworthy people they spoke to me
of certain great islands discovered some
time ago
they are called the islands of japan
our holy faith they say could there be
more profitably propagated than in any
other part of the indies
because the japanese are very desirous
of being instructed
so wrote francis xavier co-founder of
the society
of jesus the jesuits a young
militant catholic missionary force full
of christ's love
and keen to share it founded in 1534
the new order received papal recognition
in 1540
they immediately sent their first
missionaries to asia
under the protection of the king of
portugal
the jesuit missionaries recorded reams
of information about the lands where
they found themselves
and japan was no exception
alessandro valeno a dedicated scholar
and compulsive chronicler dispatched in
1574
wrote that the people are white and
cultured
even the common folk and peasants are
well brought up and so remarkably polite
that they give the impression that they
were trained at court
in this respect they are superior not
only to other eastern peoples
but also to europeans as well
it was not all positive though valignano
could not bear
their great dissipation in the sin that
does not bear mentioning
this they regard so lightly that both
the boys and the men who consort with
them
brag and talk about it openly without
trying to cover the matter
up the fanatical missionary zeal of the
jesuits meant that they would stop at
nothing to forward their aim of saving
souls for the catholic christ
including supplying weapons and
facilitating the traffic of japanese
children by portuguese merchants
better off a slave in a christian
household abroad
than a free pagan at home slave trading
of course did not endear the portuguese
or the jesuits to many of their japanese
neighbors
nor did the fact that they organized
pagan monument destruction day trips
where after the obligatory picnic even
small children
were encouraged to smash japanese
religious statues
destroy shrines and burn temples
many started to question missionary
activities
often by force of arms in 1587
the supreme warlord imperial regent
toyotomi hideyoshi
declared japan is the country of gods
but has been receiving false teachings
from christian countries
this cannot be tolerated any further
these padres cannot be permitted to
remain in japan
they must prepare to leave the country
within 20 days
he never enforced his edict it was more
of a shot across the bow
behave or else the flames of an already
violent age
were being fanned to extremes
but the jesuits held on despite
increasing persecution
they possessed a great hefty hook which
the japanese could not quite wean
themselves off
an irresistible asset
[Music]
in response to rampant and rapine
japanese piracy
the occasional battle on chinese soil
amongst competing japanese clans
and the lack of a central japanese
authority with which to deal with in any
civilized fashion ming china
japan's traditional trading partner had
cut all ties
and forbidden all trade in the middle of
the 16th century
the chinese silk medicines scrolls of
learning team munitions porcelain and
artwork
craved by the japanese market was no
longer delivered
by legal means the portuguese and their
jesuit allies could provide these goods
via their new southern china base of
macau
and in large quantities too they slipped
swiftly and
neatly into the role of middlemen
between the two feuding
oriental cousins funding their japanese
mission
and eventually much of the nascent
portuguese empire with the proceeds
meanwhile news of the jesuits exploits
was beginning to leak out around a
warring europe
wars caused by cracks in the image of
the one true god
the jesuits had been peddling in the
east
[Music]
you shall understand that the hollanders
have here an
indies of money for out of holland there
is no need of silver to come into the
east indies
for in japan there is much silver and
gold
so wrote william adams a navigator from
southern england
he stared blankly out of the window of
his edo townhouse
at the strange land fate had made his
home
his ship the dutch vessel de leifde had
wrecked in kyushu in 1600
one of the first protestant vessels to
arrive in this new world
he had come from a world torn into by
sectarian struggle
european wars of reformation that had
been bubbling for almost a century
neither side catholic nor protestant
could strike a decisive blow
the upstart heretic protestants needed
to be wiped out
and their memory expunged from history
and rivers of gold and silver
were needed to maintain the armies and
armadas
which would do just that
the protestants themselves did not feel
much like reverting to the old faith
and would fight to the last to maintain
their beliefs but they were pressed ever
harder militarily and economic blockades
bit
tight they saw the source of the wealth
that drove the catholic war machine
and determined that they too would tap
these riches
the prime protestant movers were the
dutch and the english
at first ambitious and ruthless men of
elizabeth the first
court like drake hawkins cavendish and
raleigh
today among england's most revered
national heroes
turned pirate and raided catholic
settlements and ships in the atlantic
pillaging and burning from florida to
brazil
francis drake achieved the second
planetary circumnavigation
when the threat of spanish attack
persuaded him to cross the pacific
rather than running the atlantic
gauntlet once more
in doing so he named what is now
california
nova albion before swiftly sailing away
no doubt much to the confusion of the
local peoples
and thomas cavendish in the course of
the very first planned circumnavigation
very nearly reached china and japan in
1587.
but it was adams at the dawning of the
17th century
who was to finally infiltrate the
distant land
his first few days had been consumed by
escaping execution
the vile treacherous jesuits tried to
whisper lies of piracy into the ears of
the emperor
but japan's ruler tokugawa ieyasu had
proved uninterested in barbarian
squabbles
and far more interested in milking this
new kind of barbarian
for as much intelligence as possible
he had been fascinated to hear how much
information about europe
the jesuits had kept from him in
particular that catholicism was not in
fact
the universal religion as they had
always
claimed adams had been naturalized
granted two swords the mark of a samurai
a large thief a wife and the extremely
rare right of personal
audience with his new lord he rose
swiftly in the shogun's ranks
court interpreter trusted advisor
shipbuilder
and gunnery officer he had a remarkable
talent in the art of gunnery
and instructed a great number of
soldiers in this art
which caused him to be highly esteemed
he is perhaps the most famous
foreign-born
samurai in history
[Music]
the catholics had been right to fear
this moment and what little trust
japan's rulers had had in them finally
trickled away
as no doubt adams and other protestant
visitors wasted no time in highlighting
the jesuits bending of the rules
soon the new english and dutch east
india companies
had set up trading posts and by late
1613
hiyasu had decided to act against the
jesuits
he ordered one of his chief advisers the
zen prelate ish in sudan
to draft up a manifesto with exactly
what spiritual life in japan comprised
and what it did not
japan was shinkoku the realm of its own
divinities and spirits
the kami purveyors of jaku
pernicious creeds must leave the realm
this not only comprised catholics but
also other antisocial groups
including radical buddhists the first
steps were deportation
of fanatical foreign clerics with their
most important disciples in 1614
and tolerance of common and
non-extremist believers
who were encouraged to revise their
mistaken doctrines
and indeed as most of the catholics
numbering around
three hundred thousand only slightly
short of the modern figure with a
population now
ten times the size had been ordered to
convert by their liege lords
often being baptized in groups of
thousands this caused
few problems
and yet it turned out that the
portuguese were not quite as devout as
the japanese had believed
japanese silver meant as much perhaps
more to them
and trade continued much as before
however illicit missionaries continued
to arrive and a hardcore of stubborn
japanese catholics
seemed reluctant to abandon their
nefarious doctrines
the government saw that after centuries
of bloodshed had warped japan's very
fabric
the unity and peace of the realm had to
be maintained
torture it would have to be
an official report from kyoto read it is
said
that the people who did not want to
apostatize were put naked
into rice bags which were piled along
the river
between shijo and gojo at first they
were reciting prayers
when nobody seemed to care about them
and they realized they were going to die
of hunger
and would earn no merit of fame they all
wanted to apostatize
they asked for help from the guards who
laughed a lot at this and
freed them from their bags eventually
all catholics japanese asian african and
european
were expelled or annihilated
japanese christian refugee communities
popped up
all over asia and small groups and
individuals
traveled the world one of these intrepid
people
was petro kibe
kibay stumbled down the side of the ship
to a waiting skiff
it was all that he could do to hold on
the voyage via malacca and southern
india had been the worst experience
of his life expelled from his home in
1614 for his heretical catholic beliefs
he had watched the sea forelonely
throughout his voyage
many of the crew had died and in goa the
hospital's meager beds would swiftly
fill with sick survivors
of one thing kibei was sure he was not
getting on a floating coffin like that
again
on discharge from the hospital he walked
out and kept walking
nearly three years later he reached
jerusalem
[Music]
his route and his adventures are lost to
history but it is thought he walked via
baghdad
the first japanese person to visit
palestine must have been shattered
and he reluctantly took ship for rome
where he was ordained in 1620
finally fulfilling the reason for his
earth spanning odyssey
now father kibe he took a more
conventional passage home
eventually reaching japan in 1630 able
to blend in better than other
missionaries he managed to evade capture
for nine years
while wandering the land tending to
forlorn catholic communities
during the inevitable anna surushi
torture he so
incensed the guards by encouraging his
fellow sufferers not to recant
that they pulled him out of the death
pit and ran him through
he was made a saint in 2008
kibei was far from the earliest visitor
to the far west
indeed the first japanese embassy to
europe had been decades before
led by the later jesuit mensio ito in
1582
he had been organized by otomo sorin
daimyo an early adopter of catholicism
after meeting founding jesuit francis
xavier way back in 1551.
the mission met two popes and numerous
heads of state
leaving a remarkable document curated by
valinano himself
to extol the virtues of the distant
continent to the people back home
you will come to appreciate how wealthy
and powerful the kingdoms of europe are
but it is certain that the smallest
european kingdoms contain
at least 80 or 100 leagues which equals
150 of ours
and with regard to the population and
wealth of european cities and towns
they were so great as to leave us
astonished
in 1613 a second european embassy
followed
led by hasakura suninaga making a stop
in south america
becoming the first japanese embassy to
set foot in the new world
and spawning the remarkable story of a
sword fight
between samurai and spaniards on arrival
to acapulco
and indeed following this japanese men
that settled in mexico city
seem to have exploited their skill with
sharp blades to corner the city's
barbering industry
prominent japanese exiles in thailand
formed the king's bodyguard
and in cambodia and vietnam japanese
catholic merchant families
came to control much of these states
international trade
often acting as middlemen for the
europeans
few inhabited corners of the world did
not see a japanese person
during the early 17th century
back in the land of silver and gold
english merchants could not turn a
profit
and left japan voluntarily in 1623
three years after the death of their
influential manic court
william adams who by this time was known
on the sea lanes of east asia
by his japanese title miura anjin
by 1641 of all the europeans only the
dutch had stuck it out
as long as they confined themselves to
the island of dejuma in nagasaki
paid appropriate respect to japan's
rulers removed all religious
paraphernalia submitted
regular reports on world events
renounced arms and
supply to the desired commodities the
dutch
were tolerated and so
finally after many false starts the era
of sakoku closed country
had truly begun
[Music]
the policy of sakoku was not seen at the
time as anything particularly strange
indeed in the 1640s many countries
restricted their international relations
to some extent
and japanese trade in fact increased for
at least the first century
even well into the 18th century the
german dr engelbert kempfer
who lived in japan for two years while
in dutch service praised the japanese
government
for ensuring eternal peace in the realm
it was only in later eras when an
increasingly aggressive europe came to
believe in its divine right
to travel and trade anywhere it chose
that sakoku restrictions attracted
serious criticism
on the international stage and of course
as before during the long years of
restrictions
desirable elements were mostly welcome
so long
as they obeyed the rules
[Music]
every year hundreds of chinese ships
visited nagasaki the port designated for
legal dutch and chinese trade
that the chinese government still
forbade trade with japan and called all
such merchants pirates
was irrelevant they declared false
destinations before leaving their home
ports
and then reappeared with contraband
laden junks later in the year
korea was another avenue for chinese
goods japanese merchants from the
western island of tsushima
operated from a restricted enclosure in
the city of busan
in addition a route was carved to the
south where scores
of sun-bathed wind-ravaged islands
stretched
lazily like a rope down the earth's
curve towards taiwan
and china the ryukyu kingdom
now known as okinawa which since a swift
and brutal
1609 invasion had been under japanese
control
very much as in the caribbean sugar and
other plantation industries were
established to serve an ever-increasing
metropolitan demand
for exotic luxuries the locals were
disarmed
thereby giving impetus to develop the
ancient native arts of fighting
empty-handed
or karate a method of defense which
after going through a number of
mutations was reborn
as the modern sport now practiced by up
to 100 million people around the globe
the key was the fact that despite the
ongoing official ban on trade with japan
china enjoyed an extensive official
trade with ryukyu
which included products such as ivory
from as far away as africa
so whenever a chinese mission made port
the japanese
hid
finally an ever-growing trade developed
with the indigenous inhabitants of the
misty
ice-bound islands to the north a people
who we know today
as the ainu of hokkaido but then
were known as ezzo the wild
ezzo world stretched far north well into
what is now russia
but in the 17th century no one much knew
or cared about settling in those
inhospitable untamed lands best to leave
them to the fur clad
elaborately tattooed natives who were
ripe for an exploitative trade in rich
local natural resources in exchange for
rice
alcohol and weapons one trade product
that endures on japanese tables to this
very day
salted salmon stands out a stable
breakfast food
and common filling for rice balls it is
one of the few japanese words
to be derived from the ainu language
shaki
no japan was not truly closed
the japanese simply enforced their
border controls and enacted extremely
strict
immigration policies something that all
modern states take for granted
existed in japan hundreds of years
before western countries were strong
enough
to enforce such policies in their own
realms
but the japanese government did
effectively close the world
to her own citizens in the years
following 1633
the regulations on foreign travel got
tighter and tighter
until no japanese person was permitted
to travel outside of japan
on pain of exile or death
any that found themselves elsewhere even
by mistake or bad luck such as a
shipwreck
had to stay there no return
was allowed
[Music]
the year was 1614 john sayers stood with
his head
hung low in shame as the fire crackled
and popped captain of the first english
east india company ship to reach japan
he had been proud of his voyage and of
the titillating merchandise
he had acquired for the journey home
after cheerfully displaying it on his
ship cabin's walls
his plan was to store his secret
treasure temporarily with the other
goods
in the house of sir thomas smith the
first governor of the honourable company
and a good honest christian
but unsurprisingly perhaps on discovery
mr smith had not taken it well and had
with a sense of drama put them into the
fire where they continued till they were
burnt
and turned to smoke saiya's novel
collection was no more
the first recorded export of erotic
shunger pictures
from japan meeting a quick end
english society of this age had no means
of incorporating extremes of exotica and
alien world views into its midst
difference licentiousness and otherness
was consumed swiftly
in the purifying flames popular as
shanga were
japan had much more to offer the far
west and following
england's withdrawal the dutch east
india company enjoyed a lucrative
monopoly on direct japanese trade with
europe
for two centuries they exported not only
shunga pitchers
a commodity commonly sold by
door-to-door peddlers in early modern
japan
but also silver porcelain furniture such
as desks and cabinets
tea exquisite works of art expensive
novelty gimmicks and
numerous other products japanese
porcelain in particular reached a huge
volume in the 17th century
and copied and nativised styles like the
willow pattern grace european
and american tables to this day without
the diners having any idea of the rich
history to be found
beneath their food it is even thought
that drawers were introduced to europe
through japanese import furniture
commissions could also be sent around
the world two examples from the 18th
century were fine lacquerware portraits
of frederick the great of prussia
thought to have been ordered specially
by an admirer
and europe had much to offer japan as
well since the time of the jesuits
european and asian novelties such as
telescopes clocks
oil paintings microscopes eyeglasses
maps wines globes
even exotic animals had found a ready
market in noble japanese circles
lords and ladies simply indicated their
desired products
a list was delivered to the other side
of the globe and a few years later
the products would be found displayed
upon tatami mats ready to be enjoyed
the dutch were in effect pioneering the
first
global mail order business
however in the 17th century european
books
were still strictly forbidden the
dangers of the foreign dogma
still lingered in the japanese memory
any intellectual infection
however unlikely or mild seeming would
not be allowed
to wreak the havoc it had in the past
but by 1709 memories of that painful
episode
were fading into the fog of history
[Music]
arai hakuseki ernest scholar and senior
government advisor
secretly observed his strange visitor
through a latticed screen
the european priest was kneeling his
wrists tied behind his back
his head bowed deeply to the tatami mats
it was the sixth year of hawaii in the
japanese calendar 1709 as the catholics
calculated it
this interrogation was a welcome
diversion from the incessant intrigue
court where shogun tsunayoshi derisively
called the dog shogun for his wielding
of the death penalty for those who
harmed canines
was attempting against the wishes of his
wife to adopt his boy lover a successor
arai was personal tutor to the shogun's
official adopted heir
his nephew irenobu any new candidate
would be a disaster arai put aside his
concerns and tried to concentrate on the
matter at hand
the priest's name was giovanni batista
sidoti
and he was the first missionary in
living memory to foolishly attempt to
enter japan
illegally by his own admission he
desired martyrdom
and had come to japan to achieve his
dream
this extreme novelty had aroused ari's
interest and he decided to talk
with the man
the conversations that these two men had
over the next months and years
would be the first japanese attempt for
a century to understand the european
world
and its strange beliefs sudoti explained
global geography
the religions of the world and other
matters of interest
and arai recorded these ethnographic
findings
in several volumes as a rule
in each section of the world there is a
doctrine that is held with esteem
there are only three different types one
of these is called christian
this is the law of jesus the second type
is called heathen or gentile when i
asked him about this
heathen l'oreal sect he told me that
they erect numerous buddhas and serve
them
but if this was in fact teaching he
failed to explain in what it consisted
sodoty was recorded unheard of
privileges for a criminal and housed
comfortably at a special residence built
in 1646 to imprison stray missionaries
he was given relative freedom within the
grounds as long as he agreed
to strictly obey the rules on spreading
his religion
but of course the priest was unable to
resist
and when discovered not even arai could
save him
sadoti was left in a hole to die
his wish for martyrdom fulfilled
his bones were found exactly 300 years
later
in 2014 during an archaeological
excavation
but the legacy of arai and siddhoti's
meetings and debates was to live on
and sparked a revolution in japanese
learning about europe
when arai's protege became the next
shogun after sunayoshi's enraged wife
had murdered him
this knowledge fed directly
international policy
the japanese called this knowledge
rangaku or
dutch learning and little by little over
the 18th and 19th century
it gained a serious following
alongside the traditional chinese
classics european medical treaties
encyclopedias and books on social
systems history the sciences military
strategy geography
politics economics and industrial
processes were all devoured by a
strictly controlled but eager
scholarly class this movement
along with a great expansion of
education in general
led by the early 19th century to advance
techniques in many fields
indeed telegraphic machines large guns
and primitive cameras
had been constructed in japan well
before perry arrived in 1853
notable medical achievements included
the first ever operation
under anesthetic for breast cancer by
the surgeon hanauka
in 1804 and the introduction of
vaccination by various doctors in the
first half of the 19th century
but prime among them was in the field of
electricity
simple instruments were developed in
japan from european writings or
imported models they sold widely as
curiosities and were also used in
scientific exploration
including the lifelike animation of
dolls with static electricity
and on one notable occasion the
successful experimental electrocution
of 100 schoolboys the scientist
responsible for that fiendish trick
hashimoto tsukici published japan's
first treaties on the principles
of electricity in 1811. it described not
only his own discoveries but also those
of western scientists
such as benjamin franklin
and franklin was not the only american
statesman to rise to fame
in japan despite it being only in 1809
that the japanese found out the united
states had become
a country at all after noticing american
ships arriving in their ports
the dutch helped them out of their
confusion by reporting to the shogunate
during the war for independence a very
capable general
washington by name fought bravely
against english forces
and led the americans to the final
victory several years before his death
the americans established a new city and
named it washington
in honor of his great service to the
nation
rumors of washington's exploits would
only rise in fame over the rest of the
century
and that was where much of japan's
understanding from these distant lands
came from
second-hand sources through the dutch
dutch learning though it wasn't long
before japan was once again dealing with
the west
face to face
dressed as a european nobleman stood
bowing
deeply amongst the grandeur of sarskey
cello
catherine the greats and petersburg
summer residents
it was 1791 he'd been granted an
audience with the empress herself
to beg for permission to leave her
empire and return to japan
it was the first of several audiences at
which catherine was to quiz him
carefully
and listen to competing plans of how he
could be used to open trade to aid in
the development of the russian
far east russia is the only european
country that shares a border with japan
and during the 18th century moscow's
empire which eventually extended as far
as california
was struggling to develop its far
eastern provinces
the great reception chamber was like
nothing the humble mariner had ever seen
before
perhaps a slice of heaven on earth
he felt dwarfed and overwhelmed
the towering pure white walls dripping
with gold
were covered with embedded chinese vases
paintings and mirrors which caught and
magnified the rays of the pale summer
sun pouring in through the vast windows
it was a far cry from the humble wooden
residences dakota had experienced
elsewhere in russia
but he pulled himself together and told
his story in the swift and fluent
russian that he had learned over the
long
cold and tiring years of his exile
his ship had been caught in a storm in
1782
and after seven months of drifting
reached amchitka
now one of the westernmost islands in
alaska known for being a site for
post-world war
ii nuclear weapons testing but then a
part of the russian empire
as no direct return to japan was
possible that kokuya found his way
through the stormy icy wastes of
kamchatka
into siberia and onto erkutsk well over
5 000 kilometers
from the desolate island where he had
cast away
there he met eric laxman a russian
clergyman and scientist who immediately
recognized the potential for opening
trade with japan
and accompanied him to saint petersburg
another six
thousand kilometers westwards taikokuya
escorted by laxman at all the imperial
audiences managed to persuade catherine
to fund a voyage
to repatriate dakokuya and his men and
attempt to extract trade privileges from
the japanese government
[Music]
the mission was commanded by laxman's
son adam
an officer in the imperial russian army
adam laxman
reached hokkaido in 1792 and
astonishingly
was allowed not only to land but also
received with amicable respect
and recorded gifts by the shogun's
direct representatives
he was however politely informed that
foreign ships were only permitted in
nagasaki
and was therefore instructed to inform
his government that should they desire
to dispatch more ships than they should
be sent there
laxman appeared to have won a concession
russian ships would be allowed to trade
in nagasaki
the first europeans other than the dutch
in a century and a half
however when other russians tried to
make good on these concessions in 1804
they were turned away and their gifts of
tribute returned
the spurned russians departed and
expressed their frustration by burning
some minor japanese settlements in the
far
north in the hope that this would
persuade the japanese to return to the
negotiating table
it did not and the west was kept at bay
but of course this wasn't the end of the
second wave of western attempts to prise
open
japanese trade it was just
the beginning
the english frigate hms phaeton glides
smoothly past the numerous small islands
at the narrow mouth
of nagasaki bay captain fleetwood palu
a young officer known for his rash
daring actions and harsh discipline
progressed slowly along the lengthy
expanse
the settlement of nagasaki itself lying
directly at the end of the channel
and located dead in the middle of the
bustling seafront
was the dutch training post
[Music]
atop pelu's main mast flapped an odd
flag
that of the dutch republic a state
destroyed 13 years before in a popular
uprising supported by the revolutionary
french republic
secondly above the trading post itself
that same
obsolete pendant stood it was in fact
the only place on earth where it still
flew
so as not to alarm their japanese hosts
the dutch merchants had attempted to
conceal the demise of their nation
to protect their lucrative and unique
trade
and even after the dutch east india
company had been dissolved in 1799
they simply continued as before
pretending
all was well pelu an ambitious man
seeking his next promotion
was on the prowl for dutchman in the
japanese waters
any prize he took would struck a small
blow against the newly birthed kingdom
of holland
whose king napoleon's brother louis was
allied closely with britain's enemy
france this was tantamount to an act of
war
against japan a country with zero
involvement in the conflict the japanese
officials and dutch factors were
surprised but
pleased to see what they thought was a
friendly ship
and eagerly sculled out to meet the
phaeton as she cast anchor
what happened next probably seemed like
nothing special to pelu's crew
but it changed the course of japanese
history and put it
on the road to perry's incursion
[Music]
the unsuspecting dutchman led by jared
schimmel
was seized and held as prisoners of war
while the japanese officials
and interpreters dived frantically into
the chili harbour waters to escape pelyu
ran up the british naval ensign
his true colours and demanded supplies
of food
water and wood allegedly threatening to
destroy
japanese and chinese shipping
the japanese were totally unprepared and
ill-equipped to deal with the british
raiders
and in the event dozens of ships and
thousands of samurai from nearby
dominions had to be mobilized
but before they could fully deploy palyu
having determined that there was nothing
of interest had released his captives
taken the supplies and sailed gracefully
arrogantly and obliviously off into the
distance
without firing a shot
it seemed like a quiet end to an awkward
standoff
but it was not the end for the japanese
they were accustomed to respectful
behavior from peoples they regarded as
lower
on civilization's ladder this was the
first sign
that the barbarians might no longer know
their place
it was a shock a blow to national pride
and worse
there was nothing japan could do about
it she had no means of applying military
force beyond her borders or even
protesting to a foreign government the
all-encompassing
global european war fought from the
americas to java
had finally reached these tranquil lands
where there had been little
or no conflict for nearly two centuries
one of the longest sustained periods of
peace
in human history indeed though no shot
echoed around the steep mountains of
nagasaki bay that day
the incident was to have far reaching
consequences
in response to the phaeton and several
other episodes in the coming decades
new don't think twice regulations
requiring
all unknown foreign ships in japanese
waters to be immediately repelled by
gunfire
were introduced nagasaki and other
strategic places on the coast
now brimmed with artillery the
barbarians
would not be permitted to humiliate
japan and her ruling clan
the tokugawa ever again
and standing on nagasaki docks and
gazing
intensely as pelu humiliated his country
with such ease
was a ten-year-old called takashima
shuhan it was to be the defining moment
of his life
[Music]
during his teenage years he saw that
peace had eroded the warrior instincts
the japanese so prided themselves on
that
would all have to change and he was the
man
to lead it in adulthood he ordered a
whole plethora of books
on military science and working examples
of modern weapons
cannon mortars and the latest handguns
and rifles
through dutch merchants he settled down
to study how the barbarians made war
why they were so good at it and
strategize how to deal with the
soon-to-come attacks on japanese
sovereignty that he foresaw
the military school he established
attracted students from far and wide
and in the early 1840s following china's
devastating and epoch-defining defeat in
the first opium war
he was summoned to the capital edo by
igawa hidetatsu
a high-ranking government official
charged with strengthening maritime
defenses
against the now widely expected european
assault
most in positions of authority now saw
it was only a matter of when not if
lord egawah knelt on the tatami back
ramrod straight with his sword displayed
upright beside him
he calmed his mind to take it all in
behind him blue and white striped silken
makku screens rustled gently
what he was about to observe he hoped
could be the answer
to the numerous problems his orders to
improve defenses had thrown up
his heart beat fast in nervous
anticipation
before him appeared 125
european-style rifle-wielding uniformed
infantry
divided into two companies they marched
drilled turned stopped loaded and fired
as one
no swaggering samurai moving in
haphazard lines
dressed any way they pleased no casually
shouldered spears
just neat disciplined minimalist
movements as the day progressed igawa
witnessed the two companies and four
cannon blasting an imaginary barbarian
enemy from the field
with ease he was elated takashima's
revolutionary squadrons could be
deployed against the barbarians
using their own methods
know your enemy know yourself win
a hundred victories
he knew his recommendations would meet
opposition from those who preferred to
bury their heads in the sand
but this was the future this was the
only way to protect the realm
and ensure international relations on
japan's terms
indeed china had proved that valor and
numbers alone
were not enough the celestial realm had
fallen to only 4
000 troops like these japan
could not must not yield so easily
the charismatic lord understood that
japan needed the technology to make her
own
cannon not just the old-fashioned models
little change from two centuries ago
but great powerful guns to deliver
modern steamships
to watery graves the answer was the
reverberating
furnace to make higher grade steel and
higawa's plant was one of several to be
attempted in the 1840s
this technology far beyond most
industrial process thus far attempted in
japan
took time to perfect and it was not
until the 1850s that they became
operational
the guns were cast and then the next
stage of igar was planned
production of the first warships for a
quarter of a millennium
began these ships required the mastering
of multiple
new industrial processes such as the
manufacture of steam engines
and were a vast step forward far beyond
even the complicated furnaces themselves
although a small prototype steamboat was
constructed by 1855 just after perry's
visit
it was not for another 10 years that an
effective fully operational modern
vessel was manufactured
the rio fumaru
in 1862 the slow progress on steamship
technology caused takashima shuhan to
advocate the purchase of 200 foreign
steam ships to ensure national security
this ambitious project was never
fulfilled although several dozen were in
operation by the end of the decade
these including japan's first ever
ironclad warship
kotetsu which had been built in france
for the american confederacy
but arrived too late to be much use in
the civil war
the usa sold it to japan for forty
thousand dollars
in 1867
with the benefit of hindsight takashima
and igawa's forward-thinking actions
were obviously correct
but at the time it was far from clear
there were those in high-ranking circles
who believed that spirit and bravery
would be enough to win the day
as it had always been crucially these
men and women had never seen
modern war machines in action and could
not conceive of their size and power
nor could they even contemplate that
these contemptible barbarians
now consider themselves culturally
superior
so at the very time when drastic action
was clearly needed
the government descended into infighting
and inaction
the scholar izawa seishisai described
the debate
in these terms some dimwits argue
the warriors of our divine realm have
been peerless throughout the world since
antiquity
the barbarians are puny runts there is
no cause for alarm
true the fighting men of our divine
realm are brave and skilled in warfare
and our customs reinforce this but times
change
there are errors of weakness as well as
strength during the warring states
period
our warriors were truly fit for combat
proper movements on the battlefield were
simple
reflex actions our warriors prove their
valor through actual
battlefield achievements but 200 years
have passed since our warriors last
tasted battle
how many of them today are trained well
enough to cope with the sudden thrusts
and faints
or the other complexities of warfare we
do not observe
foreign troops directly nor do we gather
information about them
once war breaks out they may engage us
in a totally
unexpected way so it is a poor idea to
rely
solely on our reputation for valor
in the end takashima shuhan was put
under house arrest in 1846
for subversion and treason
igawa continued upgrading coastal
battery emplacements
but was not permitted to develop land
forces
and so in 1853 when perry steamed into
edo bay japan was still hopelessly
unequipped to deal with the intrusion
the arguments infighting and inability
to perceive that the world had turned on
its axis
and the east was no longer at its center
was to continue for more than a decade
japan had rediscovered national
humiliation
and politics as well as foreign
diplomacy
and war these forces emanating from the
actions of commodore perry
would be the catalyst for civil war and
then
a national rebirth the meiji revolution
japan was behind in technology but not
too far
and the foundations of the coming
scientific and industrial revolution
have been well laid the japan of the
future
would look nothing like that of the past
clothes diet medicine social relations
religion
architecture agriculture industry
culture politics
education and war every field of human
endeavor
would be virtually unrecognizable
but japan would remain japan
independent proud and adaptable
and the incredible changes that swept
the nation
that is the second part of our story
you